[Music]
hi
my name is rica goren and thank you for
coming to my talk
from a zero to hero best practices for
setting up
our studio in the cloud so last year i
was given the keys to an incredible
treasure
and when i see keys i mean literally
keys
i was handed three product keys so that
my data science team at spring health
where i work
could start using rstudio server pro our
studio connect
and rstudio package manager now my name
is rika gorn
and i'm a data scientist i'm not an
engineer
i work at an incredible organization
called spring health
we're a mental health care tech startup
that provides a comprehensive mental
health care solution
to employers all over the world over the
last year we've been growing and scaling
a ton side note we are hiring
and our studio team would be a huge win
for a very quickly growing data science
team
so what did this mean for me and my team
well
our studio server pro would allow us to
run r in a secure remote environment and
we wouldn't have to rely on our local
computer for computationally expensive
jobs
our studio connect would allow us to
publish all of our data products
including
shiny apps our markdown dashboards
plumber apis and quickly source them to
other departments
and package manager would allow us to
centralize
and manage how our team uses internal
and external packages
so needless to say this is an incredible
win for my team
and we were super excited to get started
but
because of how quickly everything was
moving while i was given the support of
a fantastic engineer
the bulk of setting up and configuring
our studio team
would fall on me now
i'm very comfortable coding an r ide
or working with our markdown documents
but i didn't know anything about servers
or setting up an infrastructure in the
cloud but i was pretty sure that you
couldn't code up a server in an r
markdown document
so what did i do well
of course first i went to google now our
studio has a ton of great
guides for administering their products
but since these are geared for
engineering or sysadmins
i don't even know where to put all the
code the guides were talking about
and so this was the beginning of my
journey into the world of data
engineering
as i started learning i realized that
there was a huge
disconnect between resources available
for engineers and resources for data
scientists to learn engineering tasks
i also learned the data scientists
especially in smaller organizations or
startups
where their where engineering support
can be scarce
desperately need access to engineering
skills and resources
if they want to learn to quickly deploy
their own data products
so today what i want to do is i want to
share with you my own roadmap
for how to start the process of learning
data engineering
so if you're looking to set up rcd team
then this talk should be very helpful
for you
but even if your first engineering
product
includes a different server setup then
most of the stock
should also apply to you as well so my
roadmap is framed around
three different parts people so how you
can use people
around you and in your organization to
help you set up your first engineering
project
learning so the most important things
for you to learn
as a data scientist as you go on your
data engineering journey
and implementation what to do when
you're actually in the thick of things
and the weeds of your project
okay so you're about to start
your first data engineering project what
now
so even if you're going at this alone or
as part of a small group
it's super helpful to have an engineer
in your corner
it's important to understand that your
relationship shouldn't be combative
i think as a data scientist very often
you want
all the data possible you know
at your fingertips whereas engineers a
lot of times
they have particular security concerns
and are don't give you the data that you
need as quickly as you may want it
so it's important to start a good
relationship with your engineer
and to learn from them what their
security concerns may be
for your server and to understand where
their concerns are coming from
it's also important before you unjust
you start your project
to really understand the value of your
project why are you doing this
who will benefit who will use this new
server this new product
are there people in your organization
that you need to train or that you need
to bring on into your side
it's important to make sure that there's
kind of a pot of gold at the end of your
rainbow
because what you're going to be doing is
taking time away
from your regular data science tasks
and focusing on a new new skill set on
data engineering so it's important
that before you start the work that
you're doing
is going to very clearly bring value to
you
and to your team so technology and
learning
uh specifically for engineering product
uh projects
my biggest weakness when i started in
the beginning was that i wasn't
comfortable using bash
for me it was this kind of scary black
blinking command line
and i found a lot of it very unintuitive
there was one letter commands and
arguments
that were unintuitive as compared to r
so here we have on the left hand side
some r code and you can see it reads
very easily almost like a sentence you
can see what's being grouped it's being
counted
whereas the bash on the right hand side
can be kind of confusing
there's one letter commands it's unclear
what's happening
so it's important to start learning a
little bit about this you don't have to
learn
everything but start learn how to move
around in your directories
learn how to copy and paste files learn
how to log into your server
using something called ssh protocols and
make sure that you
actually have access to the correct
files and if you don't learn how to
change
the access for your files using bash
another piece of learning that's
important
take out it's important to draw out your
actual
server architecture and what i mean when
i say draw it out i mean actually take
out a piece of paper
and draw it out it can even help to look
at aws architecture diagrams on the
internet
and try to decipher what they mean aws
has a million and a half services and as
a data scientist
entering that world a lot of it can be
super daunting to understand
and so understanding what all the
various terms so all the different
softwares and products
can be really helpful and that's why
drawing out your diagram even if it's
super
simple can be helpful in organizing your
work before you start
also sharing that diagram with your
engineer can also help you
prevent making errors in your system
before you even start so
here's an example of a simplified aws
architecture diagram
when you first start drawing it out it's
important to think about
which parts can actually talk to each
other what is
public what is private and which parts
of the server
point to what other parts of the server
so here we have the vpc
or the virtual private cloud this is
your virtual
server and it's hosted on aws but you
can also host servers
on azure or applicable or other managed
services
here is where we have the meat of what
makes our studio team our city team
we have three ec2 instances or three
smaller servers that have all the data
that make up
our studio server pro connect and
package manager
so these ec2 instances live in a private
subnet
which create a layer of added security
so that random people can't just access
your server
so here we have a bunch of extra layers
of security
we have a load balancer which helps
route the correct request
to your servers we also have a bastion
or jump box which adds
yet another security layer so you don't
jump directly into the rcd server
you have to go through and add a jump
box in order to get into your server
now once again this is a simplified
model but it starts to show you what aws
products you as the data engineer
have to start setting up in the cloud
now one last piece um is another
important learning topic that's critical
before you start your project
um and this is learning a little bit
about ports and security so this is a
huge
topic but it's helpful to know just a
little bit about
how computers network and a little bit
about security management
and the most common internet protocols
that are used
this is one of those topics that
engineers seem to know a lot about
but when i was learning i found there
weren't that many resources available
specifically for data scientists so
ports are communication endpoints that
allow computers to talk to each other in
very secure ways
we have port 22 25 80 443
these are things like http https
things that you may have heard about but
it's important to learn just a little
bit about
what ports are available which ones you
have to turn on and off in your server
ssl and tls protocols are protocols that
make
secure internet communication possible
by encrypting internet traffic i like to
think of this as a handshake between
different computers
setting up these protocols requires
learning a little bit about different
certificates and configurations so it's
important to learn
what protocol you're going to be using
when setting up your project
okay so you've done your learning and
now it's time for implementation
my main piece of advice is to get
started
obviously do your research but don't
fall into the trap of analysis paralysis
i think for me as a data scientist i
kind of wanted to know everything
available
before i started but what happened is
that i did two weeks of research
and then realized i had nothing to show
for it other than
theoretical knowledge so it's helpful
here to take a lesson from your
engineering teams
and use a more agile approach where you
get started quickly you may fail
quickly but then you can get started
again just as quickly
all right so you've officially started
your project what do you do now
uh so use your engineer as a guide
and to check in on your work they can
tell you when you've done something
horribly wrong like when i accidentally
opened
all of my instances to the entire world
and they can also help you to finish
tasks that you may not have the
appropriate security clearances for so
for example
if you want to point your server at a
particular domain name
they can help you to do that and they
could also help you to estimate costs
for your server
learning so it's important to start
looking at the new data formats and
files are you going to be using in your
server
so to set up our studio team
specifically our studio
uses something called the cloud
formation template
to set up push button deployment now
when i started looking at this i was
very excited
because it looked like something very
similar to something in the r
world and that is that it looked
basically like a yaml file
so it's important to get to know these
files don't just deploy them
look at them read through them
understand their defaults so when i
started i did not look at the defaults
of my cloud formation file
and then i had to destroy my entire
stack and start from scratch
because i didn't change a really
important default so get to know your
files
get to know your file formats read
through them understand their defaults
so implementation you are going to be
making mistakes
so make sure that you set up guard rails
and fail safes
for those potential mistakes
first take screenshots of your instances
this is something that you can do
in aws when you set up your server after
you configure your server
you're actually able to take a
screenshot of it so if you ever mess
anything up and you need to go back
you don't have to start over from
scratch as you're going to be setting up
your server
there's going to be lots of passwords uh
pem keys
dot pk keys certificates save all of
these in a secure
way for example saving them in something
like one pass
don't just save them on your local
computer
and lastly write good documentation uh
write good documentation that an
engineer can follow that another data
scientist can follow
because at the moment while you're the
admin you may not always be the admin
for this project
so it's important to write good
documentation as you go along
all right so your server is set up
whether it's for our studio team
or for another project now it's time for
the fun part
which is to configure all of your
settings and defaults
so when you're configuring and after
you've set up the main parts of your
server
you need to get buy-in from the data
scientists on your team because they're
going to be the ones who are going to be
testing your deployment
so it's helpful it was helpful for me at
least to have a testing log
to write down what deployments are
working which ones are failing
and this is helpful for later when i was
actually writing my documentation
understand who's going to need to be
trained in the company alongside your
data scientists
don't bring everyone in until you've
figured out most of the bugs you don't
want to be doing demos for your product
when there's still bugs in it so take
time to set up training
and set up testing way before you're
going to be introducing it
to folks at your company you don't want
to discourage
your users and the consumers of your
product before
they can get started and get really
excited for your new project
set up time for training and make sure
that there's a little bit of time before
you actually start demoing
all right so once you've set up your
server you're now officially
the root user with pseudo access
it's important that you use this power
for good
and not for evil so learn about
different types of authorizations about
google auth
multi-factor authentication api keys
basic authorization as you're going to
be configuring your product you're going
to need to be giving
folks and your company access to it and
this has to be done in a secure manner
your engineer can definitely help you
here
but knowing a little bit about the
differences for different
authorization protocols can be super
duper helpful
and once again you may be the root user
now but you may not be the root user
later implementation
this is the fun part for me especially
get inside your server
and play around look at the important
main files so
for our studio server pro studio connect
and our package manager
i found that these five files were super
duper important
and making sure that deployment was
actually working
so when i first started i had a lot of
deployment errors and that's because i
realized
that i hadn't changed some of the
defaults in these five files
so get it into your server understand
what the paths are like
understand what the important files are
understand what their defaults are
and how they should be changed and if
and when they should be changed
all right so this is my entire system
for setting up a data engineering
project as a data scientist
so before you start partner with an
engineer and understand the security
concerns
as well as the larger value that your
project brings to the entire team
learn a little bit about bash about
ports and network administration
and draw out your aws infrastructure
diagram
on a piece of paper and when you're
ready to implement get started as soon
as you can
throughout your project use your
engineer as a guide
get comfortable with different data
formats and set up guard rails
in case of failure once you've set up
your project
take the time to train your team to test
your project
and test out any other little bugs and
issues that may come up
learn a little bit about user
authorization and root access
and then most importantly get inside
your server play around
and start changing your defaults to your
needs
and finally remember to have fun
thank you so much for taking the time to
listen to this talk
i look forward to answering your
questions and connecting over the rest
of this conference
thank you so much to everyone at our
studio and everyone at spring health
will help me with this talk
you